come intendete voi la passione per
qualcosa per me è semplicemente avere
un'idea fare di tutto per riuscire a
crearla
a prescindere da quello che dicano
pensiero gli altri ed è proprio questo
l'incipit che voglio usare per
raccontarvi questa storia è una storia
che ha molta passione molto trash un
sacco di colpi di scena e finisce come
ogni mio video con una morale che
nessuno ha chiesto
[Musica]
tutto ha inizio su steam la principale
piattaforma digitale per l'acquisto di
videogiochi io sono un grandissimo
appassionato di sparatutto in prima
persona quindi qualsiasi gioco venga
creato di questo genere lo metto
direttamente nella mia lista desiderio
un giorno mi stavo annoiando quindi
iniziò a spulciare la lista e trovo un
gioco con questa locandina chiamato
clown nightmare ed è uno di quei giochi
dove basta guardare una singola immagine
di anteprima per capire di avere tra le
mani un piccolo capolavoro
e questa immagine in particolare molto
rappresentativa della storia che voglio
raccontarvi oggi perché voi vedete
soltanto le norme testa di clown
disegnata a mano chi vola al centro di
questo circo ma man mano che la guardia
paiono sempre cose nuove il pentacolo in
alto a sinistra lo sgorbio disegnato su
quello che sembrerebbe un cartone della
pizza ma soprattutto il gigantesco clown
gonfiabile sullo sfondo per la modica
cifra di 21 e 39 cazzo ma anche una
colazione completa lo compro trovo il
gioco ed è una merda parla di questa
invasione sulla terra di dei clown
demoniaci letteralmente arrivati dall
inferno e tu devi soltanto tirare dritto
sparare a tutto quello che vedi ci sono
delle porte chiuse tu devi trovare delle
chiavi che tra l'altro per la prima
volta nella mia vita in un videogioco
ho visto delle chiavi fatte a forma di
chiave ed è talmente semplicistico e
fatto male che tu puoi anche non
uccidere nessun clown e correre verso la
fine del livello perché li sto parlando
di questa cosa qua perché io non riesco
a stare fermo quello che pensano tutti
vivendo una cosa del genere soprattutto
quando a un'immagine del genere come
anteprima è quello di pensare subito
questo gioco l'avrà fatto qualche russo
per riciclare soldi sporchi
io no io sono curioso
momento umano io voglio sempre sapere
quale sia il pensiero che c'è stato
dietro alla creazione di questo gioco a
dire sì voglio fare questa roba
quindi sono andato a cercarmi le
recensioni e alla scrittura di questo
video il gioco a tema 0 recensioni che
non è così raro per un gioco così brutto
però non è neanche normalissimo allora
sono andato nella della comunità che è
il posto dove la gente discute del gioco
e anche lì niente l'unica cosa che sono
riuscito a trovare e che un curatore ha
recensito questo prodotto clicca qui per
visualizzarlo e il curatore in questione
che ha fatto la recensione di clown
nightmare si chiama english fu l'audio è
né un tempo che lascia a tutti i giochi
che hanno l'audio completamente in
inglese
la recensione english claudio a tutti
quanti i giochi che ce l'hanno con tanto
di check quindi non conta proprio come
recensione assolutamente non è il più
strano di giochi che abbia mai visto su
steam si trova anche roba come tossire
simulator 2020 che voglio dire per un
euro e 43
siete ancora con me è perfetto perché il
primo turista arriva adesso le due righe
di descrizione del gioco sono queste una
corta campagna in giocatore singolo
cerca basata sul film clown nightmare
aperte virgolette e mai chiuse ok
vado subito a vedere lo sviluppatore che
è anche l'editore e di un uomo di nome
mark sollberger trovo immediatamente la
pagina su aim b b e questo e clown
nightmare diretto da mark wahlberg e
scritto da mark wahlberg e la locandina
parla chiaro sulla qualità che potrebbe
avere questo film ma come per quella
famosa immagine più analizzi questa
storia è più cosa ci trovi per esempio
la pagina di aim di man di clown
nightmare non ha una immagine del film
più della metà del cast non ha
un'immagine profilo ed ha soltanto una
singola recensione ed è incredibile a
una stella ed il riassunto è è tutto una
merda la recitazione fa schifo e diretto
di merda
la colonna sonora è troppo alta e
inutilmente drammatica per qualsiasi
cosa voglio dire e il tutto si chiude
con in confronto i film di ed wood sono
materiale di orson wells con la
curiosità che mi devasta dall'interno
vado a cercare il trailer di questo film
e ne trovo uno solo che a poco più di
mille viessmann ovviamente guardandolo è
un horror indipendente che sembra fatto
con quattro soldi con effetti speciali
alla buona ma fatto modi mockumentary un
finto documentario che per chi non lo
sapesse è il mio genere preferito in
assoluto di horror e voi direte non è
che io abbia visto negli ultimi anni
così tanti finti documentario horror al
cinema ed è bellissimo perché quasi
nessuno esce al cinema almeno in italia
ma se voi andate su aim di b e cercate
per genere mockumentary troverete una
lista lunghissima di mockumentary grandi
classici come cani balon lockout un po
meno classici come bad bad the way e voi
stavate dicendo mi sa che merda di
locandina che c'ha clown nightwear ecco
e avrei potuto tranquillamente smettere
qui e dire agli amici guarda ho trovato
questa curiosità a questo gioco che si
collega questo film tutti e due
indipendenti una storia carina eh
finisce lì ma la curiosità è la cosa che
più mi spinge a creare contenuti
partiamo con ordine si è mark wahlberg
è un attore regista e creatore di
effetti speciali nato in colorado che
devo dire all'attivo a una marea di roba
e da lì è stato un attimo andare sul
sito della sua casa di produzione ora
non è che il sito si presenti proprio
bellissimo però voglio dire non importa
arrivati a questo punto io non so più
come proseguire con la storia perché ci
sono tante di quelle piccole cose che
voglio farvi vedere che non hanno
l'ordine cronologico
allora partiamo dal signor marco nella
home page del suo sito la prima cosa che
si vede è una sua intervista
e c'è scritto stop video produsse credo
che il signor mark viva di video stop ma
non solo qualcuno oltre 10.000 video
stock ma in ogni cosa che fa c'e sempre
qualcosa di un pò particolare possiamo
trovare i video di un uragano di una
telecamera di sicurezza per esempio di
un poliziotto che fa la multa oppure che
ne so di un gorilla che fa la cyclette
nello spazio che vuole avere chi non
userebbe un gorilla che fa la scaletta
dello spazio per 76 euro ogni singola
pagina del suo sito ha sempre qualcosa
di trash dentro clicchiamo semplicemente
sul suo nome sarà il classico about me
possiamo vederli in casa la sua pagina
web di b il suo canale vimeo e poi ci
sono quattro donne credo attrici dei
film horror classic e scream queen
ipotizzo non è l'idea che tengono in
mano un foglio con il link del sito e
delle frasi su di lui marche is how one
man wolf park
non lo so e il poco sotto o meglio super
inquietante thank you very much
mark è come se non bastasse tra le
immagini c'è scritto filosofia
se ci clicchi finisci in una pagina con
dei video nascosti che parlano di
filosofia o sotto il coniglio c'è video
musicali che ti porta al divino musicale
c'è una sottocategoria di sito che è una
specie di blog come una grafica
completamente diversa qui si può vedere
il trailer di clown nightmare e la sua
locandina che non è proprio la locandina
del film è la fotografia della copertina
del dvd del film con tanto di 3 dollari
99 stampato sopra sempre qualcosa
qui c'è la vera e propria pagina about
mi del signor mark che spiega chi è
mark wahlberg fa video e la foto molto
mossa di un semp volete per caso del
merchandise di clown nightmare c'è anche
quello tutto il merchandise del film e
sun red bol
il link è questo di una modella che
indossa una maglietta di clown nightmare
e dell'immagine con il prezzo quindi tu
potresti avere la maglietta di clive con
il prezzo di 3 dollari domando un
pronome vado su red bubble e trovo la
locandina di clown nightmare
spiattellata su qualsiasi cosa esistente
sulla faccia della terra
manco fosse wish con le magliette di
dragon ball z e non so perché è tutto
uguale trarne una tazza vera che poi
tutte le immagini sono letteralmente
spiattellate l'orologio all'immagine
tagliata sopra e sotto la cover per il
portatile all'immagine tagliatissima
sopra e sotto la coperta matrimoniale
all'immagine in pieno centro e io ho
trovato cosa comprarmi la tenda della
doccia non è finita qui nella sezione
immagini di studio si possono trovare le
immagini del suo studio ed è proprio il
classico cliché dello studio di uno che
ama l'horror e ama farle a una delle
immagini più inquietanti che io abbia
mai visto un sacco di prox dei suoi film
la testa di un orso lo scheletro umano
uno di quegli addobbi di halloween che
trovi al carrefour molto molto dopo
ottobre a un euro e 99 c'è una foto con
la locandina di un film sul muro
chiamato blood sisters e che film sarà
mai blunt sisters a quanto pare una
merda visto che su rottentomatoes non ha
neanche la percentuale di critica ma
solo quella dell audience ed è il 17 per
cento
tutto quello che io scavo nella vita del
signor mark è sconosciuta
nessuno sa cosa sia nessuno sa che
esiste ma lui continua a farla in un
articolo che sembrerebbe slegato dal
signor mark chiamato i 25 film diciamo
sexy che si possono trovare su amazon
prime video right now al diciannovesimo
posto possiamo trovare un film chiamato
gran long rossin si scopre che il signor
marca lavorato questo film facendo
alcune scene e gli effetti visivi ma
visto come sta andando questo video è
ovvio che ci sarebbe stata la svolta
trash in un altro articolo possiamo
leggere che amazon
mari mosso il film che trattava
argomenti gay dopo che gli uomini hanno
lasciato recensioni negative una merda
totale semplicemente orribile
recitazione orribile conviene andare
direttamente su pornhub è la mia
preferita 5 facile che vomitano e tra
l'altro una persona ha trovato questa
recensione utile e più si cerca e più si
trova lui ha diretto un sacco di cose ma
la maggior parte sono cortometraggi gli
unici due film che ha diretto per
davvero solo clown nightmare e nel 2012
3.086 robot laica boss ed è un film
d'animazione non l'avrei mai detto
animazione magari una parola grossa
visto che adesso ci sono delle app sul
cellulare che fanno la stessa cosa
gratis e io volevo comprarlo ma
purtroppo in digitale nei cloud
nightmare né 3.086 si trovano si trovano
soltanto in dvd che arrivano
dall'america e questo non è proprio il
periodo per farsi arrivare qualcosa
dall'estero ma non credo comunque che lo
faccia con 3.086 visto che costa 44 euro
il di ruby e mi fermo qui perchè potrei
andare avanti all'infinito voi non avete
idea però quello che mi è rimasto da
quella tutta questa ricerca è il fatto
di essere entrato quasi nella vita di
una persona che fino a un minuto prima
era sconosciuta e aver scoperto una sua
enorme passione e di quanto lui riesca a
portarlo avanti nonostante tutte le
critiche tutto il trash tutti i casini
che si porta dietro
dentro il sito ci sono una marea di
video di backstage e si può vedere
quanto la gente si diverta tantissimo a
girare col chris screen con le
animazioni con gli effetti speciali di
merda perché ogni tanto varie attivata
una passione che sia creare contenuti
video su internet musica scrivere
disegnare qualsiasi cosa e io ringrazio
signor mark per avermi portato con lui
nel suo viaggio che quasi nessuno ha
percorso ora l'unica cosa che mi rimane
da fare è capire come utilizzare in un
video un gorilla che fa la cyclette
nello spazio